where we left off in the last few videos
we saw the Empire of the mongols
fragment into the various khanates in
the east
you've duan dynasty established by
Kublai Khan and then in the West you
have the Golden Horde the Shah got iconi
and then the ilkhanate in much of the
Middle East and Persia now as we go a
little bit further into the 14th century
and in particular the 1330s you might
remember when we studied Europe that the
bubonic plague hits and it doesn't just
hit Europe
it hits Asia and one of the causes often
given for the rapid spread is that you
had relative stability formed by these
khanates so that trade was able to
happen but with that trade you also have
the spread of disease and so the bubonic
plague or the black death of the 1330s
in particular does damage to the
ilkhanate
in Persia and the Middle East not only
the Emperor but his sons all died from
the bubonic plague and so you see here
on this timeline the Elkin it goes into
a rapid decline because of the black
death and at the same time in the
southwest corner of the chagatai khanate
a future Conqueror is born
Tim war which means iron he's often
known as Tim or Lane because when he was
young he was injured in both the hand
and leg by arrows which impaired his
movement and which is why the Europeans
called him Timur the lame which became
Timur Lane but despite his physical
impairments he's able to conquer much of
the chagatai khanate eventually and the
ilkhanate and established a dynasty of
his own the Empire gets established in
1370 when he gets affected power over
much of the western jacket.i Khanate he
comes from a Turk Oh Mongol tradition
now you'll hear these terms
Turco Mongol a lot because even though
the Mongols conquered this large swath
of territory they did so with a
significant health of people speaking
turkic languages from central asia
turkish being the most well known of the
Turkic languages and so many of the
conquerors especially the Muslim
conquerors of
Central Asia and Persia of this period
are of a Turko Mongol ethnicity even
though there's no evidence of him being
a direct descendant of Genghis Khan or
gingy's Khan he views himself as the
successor he wants to recreate the great
Mongol Empire by the time of timorous
death the timurid empire encompasses
much of Persia Central Asia the Caucasus
and the Middle East
his legacy is a bloody one as he
expanded territory and took over cities
it was not uncommon for his soldiers to
kill tens if not hundreds of thousands
of civilians who revolted against Tim
Wars rule his forces famously attacked
the beli Sultanate not hoping to conquer
India but to take it spoils in 1398 he
was able to successfully defeat the
Sultan who had battle elephants and he
was able to defeat them by sending
camels that had flames on their back to
scare the elephants and famously when
his forces took Delhi they killed
100,000 to 200,000 people and took the
spoils of the city there are some
estimates that timur's
forces killed as many as 17 million
people as the Empire expanded to put
this into perspective this is roughly
five percent of the world's population
at that time now once Tim or dies in
1405 you can see from this timeline that
is the Empire does not last long as we
get to the second half of the 15th
century it is in decline now some of his
descendants end up ruling over
fragmented portions of this Empire and
as we get into the sixteenth century
we'll see one descendant in particular
his grandsons great
grandson takes on the delhi sultanate
and establishes the Mogul which is
persian for mongol establishes the
Mughal Empire in northern India